>>Alexa: I've always been
interested in the idea
of making things from nothing.
When I was a kid I'd always
grab my Lego box and try
to make something totally
imaginary, like a whole city
or something awesome out of it.
And so when I found out
about this I'm, like, "Wait,
I'm actually building a whole
park, and not just a park--
a whole mini-world full of
beaches and cities and forests.
I'm actually getting to do something
that I don't get to do in school.
It's such an awesome feeling.
>>Alex Gilliam: We've
got posthole digging.
We've all this stuff.
It needs to also be painted.
So who wants to kind of lead what?
>>Tiny WPA is a program that we
launched, which puts young adults
at the forefront of stimulating
engagement in civic innovation
in their communities by empowering
them to design and build things
that improve their neighborhoods,
their public spaces,
their schools, etcetera.
We have ten young adults,
sixteen through twenty-five,
who have been given
this central space.
I mean it literally is the
central space in the back part
of this playground, in the second
oldest playground in this country,
to create an outdoor "maker space"
slash "adventure playground".
They are leading the charge on
designing and building this space.
>>All right, where should
the submarine go, guys?
>>Alexa: Basically, we're creating
an environment for children
where you're not taught how to think.
I'm not saying that, like,
this park isn't nice.
I mean, like, I love this
park, I mean who doesn't want
to slide down that wooden slide?
I mean, but, like, with slides and
swings and, like, spinny things,
that's just telling
you how to do things.
We're building sand castles so that
they could build their own things.
We're making submarines so
that they could have, like,
their own little adventure and stuff.
And we're building jungles
with, like, a bunch of pipes.
They could just make-believe
that they're anywhere they want.
We're not telling you how to think,
you're showing us how you think.
>>Alex Gilliam: You
gotta put yourself
in that spot, in that mindset.
If you squint real hard, you can
see it, you can see the forest,
you can see the mountains, you can
see the trees, you can see the sand.
>>Alexa: So you want the city
to be, like, near the forest?
>>Girl: Yeah, we want
them to be, like,
able to be adjustable
by the children.
And then our trees,
we're hoping, will be,
like, bigger versions of this.
>>Alex Gilliam: All those concepts
that are central to architecture
and being a good designer-- scale,
proportion, things like that--
we're doing that here, and the way
that they're designing really allows
them to test and fail and then fix it
as much as possible with
their own intuition.
So we create this process
where, you know what,
how do you know whether this works?
Well, you get in it and it's a feel.
You step out of it, you look at it.
You jump up and down on it.
Does it feel safe?
We're not going to talk about wood
grain structure in an abstract way.
We're gonna stand on it until
it breaks or until it gets close
to breaking or feels dangerous.
All of our Tiny WPA projects,
the sites really are these highly
public hacker spaces, if you will.
You know, where people can
come up and offer their ideas,
just like these little
kids did earlier today.
>>So the road stops with the
lake or goes over the lake?
>>Girl: We're building a
bridge right over there
and then we're making it go over
a lake and then it's gonna curve
around here and go back into
the city that we're making.
>>Alex Gilliam: Where
they're sort of laying
out roads and things like that.
That wasn't fully planned.
I mean that's the way we work, but
the way they could just walk up
and say, "Well, what if?"
That opens up all sorts of
other possibilities for us
that we wouldn't have seen otherwise.
And that's really powerful then for
the teenagers, for them to be able
to see how a four-year old's idea
or a seventy-two year old's
idea could have real value.
That's a hugely powerful
moment for them.
>>Man: Keep pulling that
trigger, all the way, Yeah!
All right, now that
is not going anywhere.
>>Girl: At the other parks that I
usually go to there's a whole bunch
of slides and swings and stuff.
And it's just there.
Here, you make your park instead
of the other people
and it's really cool.
>>Alex Gilliam: I saw you'll all
working together and everyone jumping
in and getting stuff done and
that's what we need to do.
This is gonna be a
really hard project,
and we're gonna have
to work really hard.
>>Alexa: I think schools are scared.
I think that they just
want to keep everything
by the book and by the rules.
And, you know, you don't really
learn until you have the experience.
I mean, like, you could give me,
like, a whole manual in, like,
how to use a screwdriver,
but I'm never really gonna
truly learn till I actually use
the screwdriver.
>>Basically, you take like
this flat side and you want
to hit the middle of
the hole like that.
>>When I first started this
I was just not very vocal,
I'm more of an observer.
>>Throw all your weight
into the hole.
>>But after I'd been to this program
I am more vocal, I'm not shy anymore,
I'm more of a person
who takes stuff on.
I'm not afraid to say
what I think now.
>>Yep, Tunica, and then
make a dirt pile over there.
>>I feel like people
should now hear my voice.
>>Alex Gilliam: So what are
some things we, you guys,
are really excited about?
>>Alexa: I'm just, like, excited
to see how this finally comes out,
and those kids just
wanted to play with it.
>>Alex Gilliam: Just to see
how far Alexa has come already
and what she's already accomplishing
in such a very short period of time,
man, it's like we're
doing something here.
And the fact that she's so
passionate about what she believes
in it's just astounding to me.
>>Alexa: I think that
school should be like this
because I have learned a lot
of things from this place
that I could just apply
in life anywhere.
I could have a career in building
because I got hands-on
experience from this.
That'd be really awesome.
>>Alex Gilliam: We're trying to
grow really empowered, motivated,
tenacious, resilient citizens
who will go out and do things.
And, you know, that ties
very much into the fact
that pretty much nothing
that we do is an abstraction.
You know, we found time and time
again that people are most motivated,
they do their best work
when things are real
and when they have tangible impact
and they can see the impact.